[Musique]
des chants et des danses traditionnelles
pour la fac orthodoxe l'occasion pour
certains enfants de minuit avec la
culture de leurs parents pour d'autres
le symbole est beaucoup plus fort
ces traditions leur permettent de
retrouver un peu de familiarité après
avoir dû quitter un pays en guerre
depuis le début du conflit en ukraine le
conseil scolaire catholique de toronto a
accueilli environ 75 réfugiés sur ses
bancs d'école
la moitié dans cette école d tobiko un
quartier où la communauté ukrainienne et
nombreuses si bien que la moitié des
enseignants par l'ukrainien
parmi ces nouveaux élèves eurent ebook à
l'eau l'adolescent a quitté l'ukraine
avec sa mère et ses deux frères au début
du conflit après quelques semaines en
pologne la petite famille a finalement
pu gagner le canada ou la tante de youri
les attendait
c'était un gros soulagement lâche sa
tente installée à toronto depuis une
dizaine d'années un soulagement aussi
pour la mère de youri qui voit
maintenant ses enfants en sécurité mais
la décision n'a pas été facile pour
autant caroline ans a laissé son mari
derrière jack brinet dit
si ce n'étaient pas des enfants je
serais resté en ukraine et je me serais
battu confie-t-elle il voulait aussi se
sent tiraillée et l'ukraine lui manque
ils sont beaucoup comme yuri avoir le
coeur gros pour venir en aide à ces
enfants des psychologues visiter
régulièrement l'école un soutien
essentiel explique la directrice elle
même d'origine ukrainienne
combien d'entre eux ont vu des scènes
qui les hantent se demandent les ordis
qu à la détresse psychologique s'ajoute
la difficulté de s'installer dans un
nouveau pays
la prochaine étape est de trouver un
logement explique dimitris apport aux
père de quatre filles dans cette église
située à deux pas de l'école on essaie
aussi de donner un peu d'espoir et de
réconfort aux réfugiés mais au delà de
la charité le prêtre appelle les
gouvernements en faire plus pour aider
les ukrainiens
régis
en dépit de ses difficultés ses enfants
ukrainiens se considère chanceux d'être
en sécurité dans un pays sûr où ils
peuvent dessiner les contours d'une
nouvelle vie sans pour autant oublier
celles qui l'ont laissée derrière ici à
midi radio canada toronto